do you wanna be the victim or do you
wanna be the gangster you like so much
you cave and keep up with your lies all
right you guys by now you've probably
seen cardi B releasing all of her
receipts of Nicki Minaj on oh my
goodness it's so many it's insane the
best part about this is that we got
all-new car Diaz and which I'm obsessed
with the worst part is we have women
against women and leaked phone numbers
oh we went there and now we're even
threatening to sue of defamation of
character they're talking about stopping
each other's backs again I mean this all
escalated really fast in this carnage
whew that's what we're giving poor gosh
I love that but hey guys I'm Courtney
teza know and joined by Katie Krauss it
seems like car TV is finally fed up with
the on-and-off-again drama with Nikki so
she addressed it all in a social media
rant
yeah this is my thing Nicki Minaj right
how you seen that I got a rag by Riley
when there is so many footages of that
night every single angle and where am I
getting Baghdad why would I be here
sitting in line like oh yeah I did this
I did that knowing that the next day
there was gonna be so much footages of
that same night basically everyone is
calling everybody a liar cardi B is
accusing Nikki of lying cause she went
on her Queen radio show yes and cardi
posted 10 literally 10 rants to social
media she's fed up is she which I would
beat you I feel like we've talked about
it so much so I completely understand
where they're coming from haha
well let's go back let's go back well I
feel like Nikki and cardi
this thing really escalated at New York
Fashion Week you know on Queen radio
Nikki basically said I will pay $100,000
to anybody who can give me more security
footage of that fight stirring the pot
per usual and then she's even tweeting
about it now and she wants you know she
said she wants that other view I just
think it's so uncalled for at this point
could not agree with you more and now
like you said yeah she's threatening to
sue Nikki for defamation of character
nikki is now asking calling for a lie
detector test we're taking it there it's
all sorts of messy oh my gosh but we
were talking about the best tweet Katie
I'm gonna let you talk about this
because not only does
Nikki what this lie detector but it
looks like someone else wants them to
come on the show for a lie-detector test
Maury Povich has offered to host both
ladies and offer administer this
lie-detector test
to both of them and Nikki is on board
with it I mean once it hits Maury it's
just on another level of drama so I'm
happy to see that things did take a turn
and we'll get there soon guys yeah but
here are some of our most relatable car
diva moments that were insults but we
kind of understood where she was coming
from yeah
first was saying that you got the
footage your cameraman got the footage
but now you're talking about you want to
pay somebody a hundred thousand if they
give you the footage yo make sense when
you're talking I thought you was the
victim I know what gets better job
you're standing on the wall talking
about I'm standing right here
miss chun-li the street fighter okay so
I understand where she's coming from but
it does kind of seem like Nikki is
hating and loyal barbs I understand
where you're coming from Nikki's been
around for a while she's earned her
respect but when you've earned that
level of respect there's just a certain
way that you handle yourself and don't
you know you don't stoop to that level
when there's a new artist in the game
well it's also the fact that clearly
she's generating publicity not only for
her Queen radio show but also her new
dip music video with Tyga every time
that she responded about something she
added that ha shameless plug right oh my
god March it sad I don't know
but I really think the message in all of
this is it's important for women to
stick together we're really in a
different time and I understand that the
rap wars have started from the hip hop
culture but at this one it's just gone
too far like let's band together
it is 2018 y'all get it together my
favorite thing that cardi said in her
rants is that she's always looked up to
Nikki yes is that she's respected Nikki
as an artist and to me it would be so
disappointing if I if I felt like my
role model was talking down on you and I
went missing me disrespecting me trying
to ruin my career there's nothing more
heartbreaking than not feeling do
somebody that I listened to ever since I
was in high school and that's crazy to
me because I show you respect they did
reach a you know middle ground in a lot
of areas but they did have some
suggestions on how they wanted to settle
this feud and can we run down these
yeah let's run them down so Nicki Minaj
she goes on Twitter and she basically
says okay I think that we should get on
live have a conversation and everyone
see us talking it out yeah we talked
about the lie-detector test
I think they should go tomorrow yep and
then she shamelessly plugged that
hey come on Queen radio like let's just
hash it out all out there my favorite
though collaborating I think a song
would be great for both of them to be on
could not agree more let's put out a new
song you guys believe me grows out of it
I just I just want to hear them exact
trap battle it out for all I care thank
you and it doesn't have to be a dislike
let's just air out all this dirty
laundry be be done with this and move on
but cardi B also had some suggestions we
could talk about it or we could fight it
out
I'm with whatever there's hope but I
have a feeling that the feud is not
completely over I'd like to see them
collaborate but I do think this might be
the beginning of a great friendship
let's keep the conversation going on all
social media comment below until next
time guys yeah I'm Katie Krauss
I'm Courtney teza know any ties no we
are team neither Nikki or Carney just
team women yep team women it will see
you guys later
you